[Music]
when you've been in the YK killing
business as long as I have you learn
some important
lessons you can call a minion many
things but dead is the best
one
you also learn that two traps are better
than one always like these ones that my
good friend Sorcerers put
down weird thing though some of the guys
we've been fighting lately are kind of
like us cool powers and
stuff just go to show you're never the
only one other people are special
too just not as special as
[Music]
me the most important thing of important
things though the rift is still safe
thanks to me
warmage oh and these other guys too they
help totally
help
[Music]
awesome
PlayStation